my name is a Yan hearsay
ally I am a resident fellow at the
American Enterprise Institute I was born
at a time say about a decade after the
independence of Somalia well I've always
carried with me around that time is the
impression of my parents and their
generation which was finally we are free
from the colonial yoke we can determine
our own destiny we are going to have our
own nation on flag on Parliament our own
army
there will be no pressure from outside
there was that and I was born in 1969 on
the 13th of November and just the month
before that on the 21st of October there
was a military coup which means for that
generation in Somalia that looked so
much forward to independence in less
than ten years that dream of freedom was
thwarted and disappointed as that's one
part that I carry with me the second
part that I carry is I grew up with the
vocabulary of freedom and shape your own
destiny and that kind of thing that was
on a national basis but it affected me
individually as well it also might but
my father was thrown into jail which
made my future and that of my brother
and sister and other half sisters
different from children whose fathers
were killed or whose parents were killed
or who went into exile immediately my
father escaped from jail and became a
part of the opposition Somali opposition
in Ethiopia and finally we when he
escaped jail he went to Saudi Arabia my
mother went to Saudi Arabia and we ended
up there and I've always had the pool on
the one hand towards the west
representing my father he was educated
in Italy and
in the United States and he was all
about individual freedoms and democracy
and that kind of thing sort of modernity
and my father my mother who after she
had left her nomadic life at around the
age of 19 had gone to Adam and was very
much influenced by the Arab Islamic way
of life and going to Saudi Arabia for
how was getting as close as possible to
Allah the prophet in the Holly house and
so on and she was very happy that's one
year that we were there in Saudi Arabia
so that is as far as surroundings shape
and the part of your age the part of
your life and that is dependent on
others that was the context that I came
out of I would like to make a
distinction in say between 8 0 to about
15 or 16 years before I was before I
came in touch with a woman called we
call sister Aziza in my secondary school
in Kenya and the time after that before
I met sisters Issa the Islam of my
family was not political so I don't I do
not remember either my father or my
mother saying that a society has to be
as you know Sharia should be the rule of
of a country or a society with one
exception
in the one year that we were in Saudi
Arabia there was no distinction between
a secular sphere and and and you know
let's see the film of Syria and the
field off of God these were intertwined
in Islam and in the one year that we
were in Saudi Arabia
we lived according to Sharia and the
state was ran through Islamic law so the
beheadings for instance amputations
every Friday the stonings that kind of
thing
that happened and there was a
distinction when atrocities in Somalia
were carried out by a secular
dictatorship that has such as Mohamed
Siad Barre my mother would denounce
condemn those atrocities but when
atrocities were carried out in the state
of Saudi Arabia thieves were amputated
people's heads were cut off
that was Sharia law and that was
something that the victim deserved
because he violated the law of God but
we left that behind us in when we left
Saudi Arabia and went into Ethiopia my
life in Ethiopian in Kenya until my 16th
year was I would just say you know
praying five times a day
it was very was there socially and
culturally it wasn't a political issue
when I meet in 1985 sistahs is a
different kind of Islam is introduced
and different meaning also from the one
I knew from my family it was a political
Islam it was very clear it was an
individual choice it was about but she
preferred to us the inner she had
struggling to simply to meet the
obligations to make sure that you play
five times instead of three times or two
times first all of the Ramadan days all
30 of them not half a day as I used to
do or a week in a month or something
like that so just adhering to the rules
every day the rules halal that are
permitted and trying to abstain from
what's her arm or what is forbidden
this is reinforced within the Somali
community because Kenya is a very
multicultural place and sisters is not
of Somali but in the Somali space there
were figures like this man we called
Baba so he able fasts for a hundred days
and he introduced the same kind of
radical political all-consuming Islam
that divides the world into
and they and the division started within
the Islamic community so we were those
of us who followed the fruits rigidly
those other Muslims who are neglectful
of the rules were considered to be
non-muslims hypocrites we had all sorts
of negative attributes for them and then
that they extended to the non-muslims my
grandmother who presented what we
generally generally would call
traditional nomadic Somali life and the
values of that tradition mainly tribal
very much
we oriented clan oriented she taught me
my bloodline because that is your that
you know you cannot survive without your
bloodline she taught us all these
anecdotes about how to survive in the
desert which animals to fear which
animals not to fear which animals to
hunt him eat and she was very
superstitious when I got ill or my
sister got ill she had no access or
knowledge of modern medicine
so she dealt with the challenges in life
with diseases with droughts and she had
superstitious explanations for it she
was a Muslim but a very different Muslim
than for instance Caesars sister Caesar
how Islam was very much diluted with her
own cultural traditional superstitions
for instance she thought it was a good
thing to celebrate the birthday of the
Prophet Muhammad which later at sister
season Vogelsong would say that was a
bad thing to do she could not read the
Quran
she had learned a few verses by heart
just enough to pray but she didn't allow
us to put the Quran on the ground she
would make us kiss the Quran and put it
on a higher surface I first clean our
hands before we touched it or anything
like that
so she was just a more of a traditional
Somali nomadic
in value system